trois jours sous les eaux 80% des
oeuvres détérioré sur les 3000 c'est un
désastre culturel
ces clichés sont pris sur le vif c'était
en juin dernier
il retrace l évacuation des collections
du musée girodet la solidarité des
professionnels de la culture
aujourd'hui ces photos sont exposées en
centre-ville de montargis jusqu'au 16
décembre
ces photos voilà bien que documentaires
ont aussi quelque part une assez belle
esthétique donc c'était à la fois voilà
une affaire à la fois l'aspect
artistique mais aussi l'aspect
documentaire et pouvoir quelque part
mettre des images sur ce qui s'est passé
permettent de mieux comprendre ce qui
s'est passé en ce début juin suite aux
inondations du 31 mai les oeuvres sont
aujourd'hui sèche et stabilisé stockés
dans des endroits secrets leur
restauration s'étaleront sur plusieurs
années le coût estimé des restaurations
est élevé à 2 millions 400 mille euros à
peu près sachant qu évidemment
l'objectif est de restaurer en premier
lieu les oeuvres qui sont présentées qui
seront présentées au musée amusé qui a
aussi été impactés fermé depuis plus de
quatre ans pour une refonte totale
le bâtiment aurait dû être livré cet été
mais il y a eu la crue exceptionnelle
l'eau est montée à peu près à ce
niveau-là honnie au moment des
inondations ce qui a impacté évidemment
le bâtiment puisque puisque le musée a
donc été touché au niveau du sous-sol et
du rez-de-chaussée
les entreprises ont dû reprendre les
travaux il y en aurait pour 1 million
d'euros de réparations à la charge des
entreprises et de leur assureur
les travaux vont se poursuivre jusqu'en
janvier et le musée devrait ouvrir au
public fin 2017